mira
existen
ah
aquí en sudáfrica por cada 100
estudiantes que comienzan el primero de
primaria solo 48 entre la secundaria y
de los 48 que entraron a secundaria sólo
22 elegirán matemáticas en su matrícula
y de esos 22 sólo 10 aprueban y de estos
10 sólo 4 aprobaran con una calificación
superior al 50%
así que por el momento de cada 100
alumnos en el sistema escolar sudáfrica
no sólo 4 terminan con una calificación
en matemáticas superior al 50% bueno mi
historia con khan academy puedo decirles
que pude pasar de 0 a 10 al principio en
primaria no sabía mucho de matemáticas
sentía que las matemáticas eran
aburridas y puras cosas negativas y
desde que llegué a khan academy siento
que las matemáticas son interesantes y
disfruto mucho también siento que mis
calificaciones mejoraron es asombroso
porque no sabía que khan academy me
ayudaría tanto ahora de verdad me gustan
las matemáticas tengo tantas historias
de chicos que progresan durante el año
tengo el privilegio de sentarme aquí y
observar las respuestas de los muchachos
mientras hacen sus ejercicios de
matemáticas practican y hacen sus
exámenes de observar cómo progresan
tenemos un muchacho que comenzó en khan
academy en el nivel 2 y ahora está
haciendo ejercicios de nivel 11 tenemos
otros chicos que empezaron tal vez en el
nivel 2 o 3 y ahora están en los niveles
5 6 ó 7 y se sienten tan orgullosos que
quieren compartirlo con nosotros me hace
muy feliz ser parte de esto y numérique
nos dan clases extra para aprender más
así que al final del año cuando llegamos
a los exámenes dominan mejor el tema que
otros alumnos y sacan mejores
calificaciones así que si por eso no
américa es maravilloso
decir que aplicamos el programa puedo
ver que hay un gran cambio en los
alumnos comparado con lo que ocurría
antes yo creo que se divierten cuando
hacen los ejercicios la gratificación
que khan academy le da a las matemáticas
es muy poderosa no me gustaban las
matemáticas y ahora sí porque se han
vuelto interesantes y divertidas es muy
entretenido aprender matemáticas
aquí en la escuela todos nos divertimos
podemos ayudarnos unos a otros y tenemos
problemas lucían siempre está dispuesto
a ayudarnos somos como una familia pero
una muy pequeña sonrisa soy
y nos encantan los
yo soy tu hit y yo soy daniel y los dos
enseñamos en la secundaria un hedor man
ser asesor significa ser activo
innovador y tratar de incorporar cosas
nuevas en una lección de matemáticas las
matemáticas para mí es llevarlas más
allá porque en la universidad va a ser
más teórico así que esto es más como en
el lado práctico también trato de que
sea divertido para que los alumnos
pueden relajarse y disfrutar y que no
sólo sientan que las matemáticas son
aburridas
mi recuerdo favorito del año es trabajar
con los chicos no solo en esta clase
sino en todo el sistema numérico que
tenemos en el campamento de matemáticas
el campamento de matemáticas es medio
loco es maravilloso creo que lo mejor
para mí en el campamento de matemáticas
es reunir a los chicos un momento
especial en el campamento fue ver a dos
chicas de lugares distintos en
condiciones geográficas diferentes y ver
las que se entienden que están juntas
todo el tiempo por eso hacemos lo que
hacemos nos gusta mucho el campamento de
matemáticas conocemos mucha gente
jugamos muchos juegos aprendemos muchas
matemáticas
quiero ser profesor y ayudar a otros
chicos a mejorar en matemáticas
en la mayoría de los trabajos necesitas
matemáticas así que hay que aprenderlas
bien yo quiero ser arquitecto yo quiero
ser doctora yo quiero ser analista
forense yo quiero ser un chef y necesito
las matemáticas para saber combinar
mejor los ingredientes mi participación
con khan academy ha hecho que me
interesen más las matemáticas y ahora lo
que quiero es aprender más primero
quiero ser ingeniero automotriz después
un empresario y conferencista de
matemáticas en una universidad también
quiero ser experto en tecnologías mi
tema favorito de matemáticas instructor
me encanta el álgebra porque hay que
resolver el valor de la equis
eso para mí es perfecto encontrar el
valor de x es mi favorito
cuando era estudiante me encantaba la
geometría pero ahora me encanta todo
todo simplemente me gustan las
matemáticas eso es todo